bonjour à tous merci de nous retrouver
en direct sur figaro live un peu plus
tôt ce matin le président français
emmanuel macron est arrivée au vatican
pour être reçu par le pape françois une
rencontre dont les images ne nous
parviennent qu'à l'instant puisqu'il
s'agit d'un d'une diffusion en différé
là il s'agit des images de son arrivée
au vatican on aura dans quelques minutes
les images de sa rencontre à proprement
parler avec avec le pape jean marie
guénois rédacteur en chef et spécialiste
des religions au figaro est à mes côtés
pour commenter cet événement et répondre
à vos questions bonjour jean marie
bonjour charles merci d'être avec nous
en direct alors c'est la deuxième fois
depuis le début de son mandat
qu'emmanuel macron est reçu au
saint-siège la première visite avait eu
lieu en juin 2018 le président il faut
préciser a été reçu à sa demande
pourquoi est il est sollicité une
audience chez le pape qu'attend il de
cette visite alors techniquement le
président comme d'autres chefs d'état
profitent souvent d'un voyage à rome
pour demander solliciter une audience
avec le pape politiquement c'est
clairement un acte de précampagne voire
de campagne électorale puisque
rencontrer le pape s'est donné
l'impression en tout cas que les
relations avec l'église catholique sont
bonnes donc que les catholiques peuvent
avoir confiance dans ce président et il
ya vraiment d'abord injuste clairement
politique mais il a besoin de rassurer
l'électorat catholique en france et
pourquoi l'électorat catholique a été
très déçu les catholiques qui sont
d'ailleurs pas du tout on ne peut pas
les enfermer dans une voie politique il
y en a deux de droite de gauche des
verts des jaunes des rouges des bleus
donc faut surtout pas commettre cette
première erreur deuxièmement les
catholiques on était extrêmement déçu
par le tour de passe passe que macro et
voulu faire aux bernardins en allant
rencontrer l'église catholique à grand
renfort de publicité donc bernardin ce
collège des bernardins à paris où il a
fait un grand discours appelant les
catholiques qui a participé aux débats à
s'impliquer dans le débat qui les
écoutaient comme d'ailleurs il a dit je
vais ce matin et côté le pape est en
fait il en est rien sorti notamment sur
les vols beauty qui n'en est rien sorti
donc il ya une part de d'actes
politiques de la part de mâcon parce que
les catholiques curieusement quand les
élections sont serrés surtout au
deuxième tour et que les enjeux se
calculait se joue sur quelques milliers
de voix parfois aux dizaines de milliers
de voix les catholiques peuvent être une
variable d'ajustement très intéressante
à ce moment là ça s'est déjà vérifié
dans des élections présidentielles
précédentes emmanuel macron le sait très
bien et il anticipe finalement cette
mauvaise humeur des catholiques à son
égard en essayant de rattraper une image
la meilleure façon de le faire c'est de
voir le pas françois de même qu'il avait
téléphoné quasiment la veille de deux
lancements des lois sur la bioéthique il
avait appelé pas françois sur un autre
sujet pour dire voyez on a quand même
des bonnes relations n'est ce pas mais
mais en réalité il faut pas se leurrer
sur l'agenda politique du président un
but lui qui est d'ailleurs de bonne
guerre alors on le voyait il ya quelques
secondes vous montrer les images de
l'arrivée 1 du chef de l'état français
au vatican voilà il sortait de son
véhicule ils étaient accueillis par
monseigneur sapienza le préfet de la
maison pontificale
l'entretien a déjà eu lieu on devrait
voir quelques images de leur rencontre à
proprement parler est ce qu'on sait jean
marie guénois comment s'est passée cette
rencontre si elle s'est bien passé et
combien de temps elle a duré parce que
je crois que la durée d'un entretien
avec le pape quand même à son arc il
n'ya pas des tarifs mais parce que c'est
un premier ministre ça peut vraiment
demi heure un chef d'état c'est entre 45
minutes et une heure et de fait elle a
duré une heure donc c'est beaucoup
il faut compter aussi de temps 30
traduction oui parce que parfois comme
la dernière fois avec le premier
ministre les deux se sont excusés sylvie
ya un peu plus d'un mois voilà ils se
sont parlé en espagnol donc vous gagnez
la moitié du temps évidemment là il est
possible qu'il y ait une traduction je
suis pas certain mais c'est assez
probable vu la technicité des dossiers
donc une heure c'était quand même un
temps un temps important c'est
significatif mais vous avez des chefs
d'état des premiers ministres y en a en
moyenne deux à trois par semaine donc ce
n'est pas du tout un événement vu du
côté du saint siège que de recevoir le
chef d'état français qui lui donne
l'impression que la terre entière le
regard en train d'aller voir le pape les
chefs d'état c'est monnaie courante au
vatican donc le protocole est très
réglée très mesuré et mme emmanuel
macron entre dans ce protocole comme les
autres chefs d'état est ce qu'on sait ce
qu'il a dit
au parc françois emmanuel macron sur
quels sujets prioritaires ils
souhaitaient s'entretenir avec alors on
n'a pas eu alors justement une des
caractéristiques c'est qu'en général la
règle ce qui montre d'ailleurs que c'est
aussi un montage en partie médiatique en
la règle veut qu'un chef d'état soit
discret et pudique sur ses rencontres
avec le pape est encore là on a eu droit
hier à une mini conférence de presse
très bien pour les journalistes où le
magma quand on va dire avant de voir le
pape ce qu'il va dire au pape à savoir
les dociles de l'immigration font les
grands dossiers internationaux du moment
la vaccination on peut le deviner donc
voilà ce sont quand même des discussions
très très large il peut y avoir un
aspect plus personnel parfois ça arrive
chef d'état peut avoir besoin de
s'entretenir personnellement avec le
pape et on voit parfois des déchets et à
sortir de ces rencontres
transformer ou liquéfié ou un petit peu
différent ému en tout cas ça arrive là
on a des dossiers très lourds notamment
la de ces d'immigration le dossier
évidemment de la crise et un grand tiers
il aurait donc il y à dents je pense le
vrai le vrai dossier central reste la
question des migrations il se trouve que
le pape va aller à chypre et à lesbos
sur les causes la semaine prochaine pour
défendre toujours son idée d'ouvrir les
frontières européennes aux migrations là
dessus évidemment le présent français
comme d'autres présidents en europe sont
en réserve mais c'est le dossier central
d'un autre côté le pape est plutôt
social démocrate de 2
millions de positionnement politique
donc conduire en centre gauche il est
très utile actuellement aux chefs d'état
européens
très utile de voir le pape pour contrer
une sorte de vague
nationalistes souverainistes populis qui
monte en europe est en fait le pape lui
regarde la france à travers l'europe et
en accordant cette audience est une
façon de soutenir pour lui pour le bas
françois la lutte contre le nationalisme
on a vu comment il a traité quand même
le chef d'état le premier ministre
hongrois quand il était allé sur place
en ne donnant que deux heures d'une dune
mais c'est en partant aussitôt sans
accueil officiel enfin c'était vraiment
une gifle à la hongrie parce que les
hongrois avaient mal voté dans son état
d'esprit donc voyez donc cette rencontre
folle le noyau de cette rencontre c'est
un acte politique apporte européennes
sur fond de crise migratoire et en vue
de repousser aussi loin que possible
dans l'esprit du pape comme du présent
macron la perspective d'un vote
populiste souverainiste si vous venez
nous rejoindre en direct sur figaro live
nous vous parlons et nous commentons
cette actualité aujourd'hui qui
concernent la visite du chef de l'état
français emmanuel macron opaque françois
au vatican le chef de l'état a été reçu
il ya quelques minutes maintenant
en fin de matinée au vatican par parle
par françois l'événement a eu lieu nous
allons vous diffusez les ihm les images
en différé sea life et veut bien nous
permettre d'accéder aux flux en tout cas
on est avec jean marie guénois rédacteur
en chef au figaro et spécialiste des
religions qui commandent cet événement
avec nous en direct si vous avez des
questions vous n'hésitez pas à les poser
nous sommes diffusés sur figure web et
sur youtube jean marie guénois cette
rencontre a été obtenue à cinq mois de
la présidentielle or en préparant cette
émission je me suis aperçu qu'en dépit
de l'usaj
cet événement a lieu en dépit de l'usagé
qui veut que le parc ne reçoivent pas de
chef d'état pendant une campagne
électorale
pourquoi le pape accorde-t-il on va dire
c'est une faveur de cette sorte de
faveur au chef de l'état français a
formellement le président vaincrons
n'est pas encore candidat même si les
informations sont exactes donc du point
de vue du pape et de l'église catholique
et du protocole il reçoit un chef d'état
en exercice
deuxièmement cette règle que vous
évoquez s'applique surtout pour les
voyages pontificaux le saint-siège évite
soigneusement de d'envoyer le pape ou
d'accepter un voyage dans un pays dès
lors qu'il y aurait à horizon de moins
d'une année une élection importante
qu'elle soit législatives ou
présidentielles enfin
personne n'est dupe et là on revient à
ce que nous venons d'évoquer c'est à
dire que le pape françois veut
encourager autant qu'il peut les chefs
d'état européens qui ne sont pas
populiste qui ne sont pas souverainiste
et là il est il est à découvert le pas
françois n'a pas peur de ses opinions
politiques
il n'a pas peur de mener des combats
politiques et cette rencontre s'inscrit
dans cette volonté de
de faire barrage parce que c'est pour
lui il s'agit de faire cela on a vu
comment il a agi par exemple avec le
président trump et comment ensuite il a
complètement changé d'attitude
avec le président biden aux états unis
toujours en raison du même sujet de la
question des migrations donc le pas
françois a mis la question migratoire au
centre de son pontificat il a des
raisons aussi de le faire on n'est pas
là pour en juger mais en tout cas c'est
un fait et
tout ce qui peut aller dans le sens
d'une politique européenne européenne
insiste un pas seulement françaises
contrôlent et nationalisme l'immobilisme
le pas françois saisit toutes les
occasions pour pouvoir faire avancer ce
dossier alors ma question sur cette
faveur qu'on pourrait penser de cet
accueil que fait le pape françois
aujourd'hui dans cette tranche cette
échéance électorale française c'est
aussi parce que certains pensent qu'il y
a une relation particulière entre le
pasa il est le chef de l'état vers
charlotte je sais c'est du storytelling
ça c'est l'elysée qui écrit c'était
cette histoire là il n'y a pas de
relation particulière entre le pas
françois emmanuel macron si c'était vrai
le pas françois serait venu en france
depuis longtemps et on dit on dit qu
emmanuelle coint est un ancien élève des
jésuites et dans cette mesure là c'était
ce que des belles histoires capter
l'attention c'est des belles histoires
faites pour expliquer aux français que
maintenant qu'on a quelque chose avec le
monde catholique et qu'il en est d'une
certaine manière est un peu comme chez
lui même si par ailleurs il a pris ses
distances personnel avec le catholicisme
non il n'y a pas de relation privilégiée
avec le entre le pas françois emmanuel
macron il faut bien réaliser que la
france vue de rome n'est pas le centre
du monde emmanuel macron n'est pas le
président des présidents et
l'église se gardent toujours de
privilégier tel ou tel
régime ou telle ou telle personnalité
elle essaie d'avoir une attitude assez
neutre par rapport au delà des dossiers
plus politique dont on vient de parler
mais en terme disons de relations
protocolaire elle est extrêmement
soucieuse de ne pas donner l'impression
de privilégier l'un ou l'autre donc
beaucoup de chefs d'états téléphone ou
pape quand il ya des sujets particuliers
il n'y a pas du tout de d'exception
macron dans les relations avec le père
françois quand on voit cette image qui
nous sert d'illustration de l'or oui
mais ça c'était le président macron au
début ces rencontres qui a osé embrasser
le câble il savait ce qu'il faisait
aussi on est dans on est dans un récit
dans un récit politique avec des
séquences qui sont pensés à l'avance et
macron allard allard effectivement de
savoir parler à l'inconscient du peuple
français par des gestes symboliques dont
celui ci et c'est ce jamais le pape ne
se permet d'embrasser un chef d'état
c'est lui si vous regardez bien les
images qui était allée embrasser le pape
savait un peu surpris le protocole à ce
moment là parce que ça ne se faisait pas
ça nous faisait ça ne se fait pas un
chef d'état ne va pas embrasser le pape
le pape en public c'est c'est quelque
chose qui ne se fait pas et c'est une
erreur diplomatique faute diplomatique
non c'est un gène le pas fort ça vous
savez c'est un trait libre wii donkey
les latino américains argentins et vous
tape sur l'épaule c'est assez un homme
est absolument pas du tout conventionnel
donc il est tout à fait à l'aise avec je
demande des relations humaines vrai il
les apprécie donc je vais pas juger non
plus ses intentions mais en l'occurrence
poser ce geste donne l'impression qu'une
relation tout à fait particulière or
j'atteste qu'il y ait une relation
normale d'un pape avec un président
parmi d'autres et que voilà s'il y avait
une relation si extraordinaire que ça
macron manuel ont réussi à convaincre le
bas françois de venir en france y est
justement le père françois siège au
vatican depuis 2013 et pourtant il ne
s'est jamais rendu en france comment on
l'expliquait ce que c'est parce que la
france finalement ça n'est pas une
priorité dans l'agenda du pape france
adresse il était venu à strasbourg et ce
avec un mini scandale c'était donc après
son élection est ce que c'était fin 2013
ou début 2014 cette fin 2013 pour aller
aux communautés européennes il avait des
livres un grand discours très beaux
discours sur l'europe d'ailleurs à cette
occasion à c'était la première fois que
le pape s'adressait à l'europe et
c'était très important et moi j'avais
été un de ceux qui disaient c'est en
2014 ça me revient maintenant à écrire
comment se dire que papa ce à quelques
mètres de la cathédrale de strasbourg
quasiment un siècle après le début de la
guerre de 1914 qui a quand même été qui
a ravagé quand on est un peu il trouve
que je suis un peu de cette région de
l'est de la france en voilà le ravage
que ces gars ont fait danser dans ces
régions et en france dans 14 cantons
doivent ils auraient été quand même pas
indécent que le pape sarr est même sans
vouloir faire un voyage en france aie
pris à la cathédrale en silence en
mémoire des millions de morts de ces
conflits puis aillent ensuite aux
comédiennes ont ils à vie dont je vais
aux communautés européennes c'était le
début du pontificat il était quand même
très très arrêtées aussi dans danton
saisies dans ce qu'ils voulaient faire
ne voulait pas mélanger la france et les
communautés européennes hees avait été à
la limite bon à la limite d'un incident
diplomatique
c'était mes dons qu'il est il n'a pas
voulu il ne veut pas venir en france
parce que la france n'est pas une
priorité pour lui et puis ya aussi
d'autres dossiers qui le chagrine en
france la france est un pays qui
fabrique beaucoup d'armes il et il
déteste ça
il n'est pas il n'est pas à l'aise avec
une certaine arrogance française
la france considère qu'elle c'est un
pays assez gâté sur le plan de l'église
a été choyé par les papes choyée par le
pape jean paul ii choyée par le pape
benoît 16 qu'ils étaient tous les deux
des francophones et des francophiles
vous sincérité totale il a reçu beaucoup
de la france c'est un dévot le pas
françoise un dévot de sainte thérèse de
l'enfant jésus il a il a toujours
histoire d'une âme dans son sac il a
deux parmi ces grosses et père spirituel
et ses inspirateurs il ya 2 et des
jésuites français très important donc il
est il est familier de ce pays et de sa
culture mais il la tient à distance
comme comment dire comme comme un père
de famille qui considérait bon ça va tu
étais très gâté maintenant j'ai beaucoup
d'autres personnes enfants à devoir
m'occuper dont des pays en difficulté et
on le voit par exemple il va il va aller
en grèce la semaine prochaine il va
lesbos retourne dans ce camp de réfugiés
ces voix là sa préoccupation ce sont les
pauvres les petits les marginaux et non
pas les pays qui ont pignon sur rue que
peut penser que peuvent penser les
catholiques français au delà de ces
aspects politiques ou géostratégiques de
cette réponse que vous faites et de ce
que ça peut ça peut probablement les
toucher de savoir que le pape considère
que voilà ce sont des catholiques
suffisamment gâtés que ce ne sont pas
des catholiques prioritaires entre
guillemets j'irai pas que c'est pas des
catholiques prioritaire et les cadeaux
qui sont les premiers à comprendre que
le pape justement dans une perspective
chrétienne s'intéresse d'abord au petit
aux plus démunis on les voit ces images
d' emmanuel macron à l'instant
diffusé en différé de sa rencontre avec
le pape françois au vatican qui s'est
déroulée un peu plus tôt ce matin une
rencontre vous disiez jean marie guénois
spécialiste des religions rédacteur en
chef au figaro il anglais qui a duré une
heure et qui de ce que vous dites est un
timing dur et d'entretien qui correspond
à celle que d'une bonne moyenne c'est
une bonne année alors c'est toujours
cordiales on le voit sur ces images là
c'est la deuxième partie de l'entretien
c'est à dire que on l'a vu assis à son
bureau juste avant qu'il ne commence
entretien en tête à tête et puis ensuite
le président fait rentrer donc une fois
qu'ils ont parlé donc l'autre première
le président fait entrer sa délégation
il doit être en train de lui offrir un
livre d'ailleurs il fait entrer sa
délégation et abbas de vivre inigo c'est
de se caler cet ouvrage ces deux livres
écrits par françois sureau sur le
fondateur des jésuites et l'idée c'est
le
surnom de ignace de loyola c'est un très
beau livre d'ailleurs je vous le
recommande
d'ailleurs dans le figaro régulièrement
j'écris un de ses seins de ses
conseillers aussi donc voilà et après
dont on fait entrer la délégation
échange de cadeaux dont des gravures des
céramiques que sais-je et puis après
voilà le peintre accompagne ce petit
monde alors ça c'est le pape vient de
montrer au pape aux présidents des sept
une lettre mais ils n'attaquent des
chapelets qui arrive aussi qu'ils sont
des cadeaux offerts là c'est vraiment le
revoir au revoir c'est vraiment la
dernière scène se disant voir et voilà
une rencontre qui est qui qui qui
doteront sans l'aspect plutôt la
tonalité plutôt chaleureuse en oui mais
le pape est comme ça le papy papin sauf
pour trump la forme ère fois là c'est le
canal par all in donc le premier
ministre l'église catholique qui est que
le président d'un buffet qui a rencontré
après sa rencontre et que c'est mon
cirque à la guerre qui est un anglais le
ministre des affaires étrangères du
vatican qui parle très bonne très bien
forcé les deux d'ailleurs parle un
excellent français
si on était aux affaires diplomatiques
tous les deux et là c'est un entretien
plus techniques sur les questions
bilatérales sur les questions
multilatérales
la place de la france en quoi le
saint-siège peut faciliter un certain
nombre de choses comme une diplomatie un
peu parallèle un peu douteux voilà donc
effectivement et c'est toujours très
impressionnant cet aspect un peu
protocolaire les marbres les gares de
suisse les couleurs
saint siège a l'art de
conserver
au nord en tout cas ses visiteurs par
une grande dignité on voit les ministres
qui suivent et je crois qu'il est le
drian également dans la voilà dans la
suite du président voilà ce sont des
images ont différé d'un événement dont
qui s'est déroulée un peu plus tôt ce
matin le pape françois recevait donc le
chef d'état français emmanuel macron au
vatican pour une une rencontre placée
sous une
tonalité plutôt chaleureuse mais avec
des intentions politiques vous nous
l'avez bien expliqué jean marie guénois
de la part du chef d'état français
vous disiez que leur temps d'entretien
qui étaient d'une heure environ et est
dans la moyenne c'est la deuxième fois
on disait que le chef de l'état
va à la rencontre du pape françois au
vatican de visites en un quinquennat
c'est plus où c'est moins que les
prédécesseurs d' emmanuel macron là on
peut pas non plus tirer de conclusion là
dessus c'est c'est ce qui est étonnant
effectivement c'est cette visite à cinq
mois des élections présidentielles c'est
une visite de faim n'ont pas de
pontificat de fin de quinquennat et la
très peu sauf françois hollande sera
aussi avait essayé de tirer sur la corde
jusqu'au bout on est on est quand même
là on peut pas s'empêcher de penser
qu'il y a qu il ya des arrière pensées
politiques et que le pas finalement
fréquenté le pape même pour des tenants
de la laïcité pure et dure c'est quand
même utile parfois dans dans
l'escarcelle politique quand les
internautes qui nous suivent en direct
mais je les en remercie quand kris kross
qui est un fidèle de figaro live
commenté en disant ça sert à quoi cette
rencontre à rien est-ce que
objectif d' emmanuel macron peuvent être
satisfaits en partie il ya un petit peu
sévère nous nous autres internautes que
je salue d'ailleurs merci de votre
fidélité est votre réaction
sert à rien non parce que c'est
justement on est dans un domaine du soft
power c'est à dire que l'église
catholique n'a pas un rôle prééminent
majeur dans les affaires du monde mais
pourtant elle est là comme entité morale
comme facilitatrice parfois de solutions
dans des conflits comme veilleur morale
comme comme vigile et donc
ça ne fait pas de mal à un état comme la
france d'avoir des relations avec le
saint-siège de même le saint siège a
besoin d'échanger de se confronter avec
des pays comme la france comme d'autres
donc bien sûr ça ne sert pas au sens
technique à quelque chose il va pas il
va pas il ne se produira pas après cette
rencontre des décisions des actions
majeures mais on entretient un mouvement
on entretient une relation qui est qui
et aux bénéfices quand même de tout le
monde du pays de la france de l'église
et de l'humanité d'une certaine manière
parce que c'est que la france a quand
même une influence internationale
importante
le saint-siège le sait et réciproquement
le saint siège malgré sa petite
apparence et ses gars de sucer ses
fleurs et tout ce qu'on a vu là et quand
même à une entité mondiale très
importante dans notamment dans des pays
en afrique continent important donc tout
le monde a intérêt à ce genre de
relation merci beaucoup jean marie
guénois de mais attention ça crée un peu
de votre temps ce matin pour commenter
cette actualité en l'occurrence la
visite d' emmanuel macron au pape
françois un peu plus tôt ce matin on
vous le voit sur ces images vous aurez
l'occasion de réécouter revoir cet
entretien que je viens de mener avec
jean marie guénois yatabaré sur place
notre chroniqueur politique il va nous
raconter sommes en détail dans le détail
dans le print et demain matin et sur
lefigaro.fr évidemment dès demain des
cdd de la fin de journée aujourd'hui
j'imagine
merci encore jean marie guénois je
rappelle que vous êtes rédacteur en chef
et spécialiste des religions au figaro
merci à tous de nous avoir suivi sur
lefigaro.fr et sur youtube à très vite
sur figaro life